Schalk: Hello, my name
is Chris Schalk.
I'm a Google
Developer Advocate.
And I'm here
with Yoichiro Tanaka,
the creator of OSDE,
which is an Eclipse plug-in
that allows you to do
Open Social Development
entirely within Eclipse.
So let's go ahead
and do a demonstration
of how to use the OSDE plug-in
inside of Eclipse.
So, first of all, after I've
installed the Eclipse plug-in,
I can create a new project.
And you'll notice
the project type here
is an Open Social project now.
And so I'll click "Next,"
and I'll just give it
a basic name like "OSDE Test."
And I'll give it a title,
like say, the same thing,
"OSDE Test,"
as well as--
I'll just fill in
the author e-mail.
You'll also notice that
I can specify other features,
such as
the Open Social Version,
as well as other
just general gadget features.
But I'll just accept the default
and click on "Next."
And now on this page,
I can create different views
for canvas, profile,
preview, home, etc.
So, in this case,
I'm gonna create two views--
one for canvas of type HTML,
and I'm going to go ahead
and create external JavaScript
in a separate file,
as well as generate a little bit
of JavaScript file
in the form of an init function.
And I'll do the same thing
for the profile view.
So you have type HTML
and generate some JavaScript.
And then at this point,
I'll click "Finish."
And this will create
our new Open Social Developer
environment project.
So I can open this up,
and so you can see
I have our gadget.xml,
so that's our gadget spec,
as well
as two JavaScript files
that contain
the code for each view.
Now, you'll notice
the gadget.xml file
is already open,
and we're looking
at an editor.
It's like a simplified editor,
so I can just enter in
the fields directly here.
Likewise, I can open up
and specify
the different options.
And now if I--Also, on the
bottom, I can tab through.
So, for example, if I wanted
to access the different views
directly through here,
I can edit the views
inside here.
Likewise,
I can change the locale
or add internationalization
for my gadget application,
same thing
for user preference.
And then finally,
if I want to just edit
the source code
directly for my gadget,
I can just click on "Source"
and edit this way.
So, in this case,
the code that's defined here
is--as a default
is actually pretty easy.
It's just a simple div.
I'm gonna actually replace
the code
with some of my own code.
And I happen to have
some code handy here.
So, first of all, I'll just
create, like, my own div,
where I'm going to display
my friends,
instead
of what's generated here.
And then, likewise, I'm going
to go into the canvas.js file.
I'm gonna open that
into a Text Editor.
And right now
it's just an empty init file--
init function, that is.
So let me switch back over
to my ready-to-go
JavaScript code.
And I'll--all I'm doing is I'm
loading in two functions--
"load friends"
and then "unload friends."
And then I'm actually replacing
the init function here.
And what this code does
is it simply goes and fetches
a set of friends and displays it
into the gadget body itself.
Okay?
So let me just
paste that in there.
And now I'll hit "Save."
So now I'm ready to run
the application.
But before I run it,
I'll actually have
to start up the local--
local server,
the local Apache server.
And so, in this case, as you
notice here on the menu bar,
there's a little icon there that
looks like the Open Social icon,
and it says,
"Launch Apache Shindig Server."
So let's go ahead
and click on that.
And that will launch essentially
Apache Shindig right here.
And you can see the progress
of it in the console.
And then once the server
is ready to go,
I'll be able to launch
my application.
And I do that
by clicking on the gadget,
and I can do a right-click
and then, as you notice here,
I've got OSDE
and then "run application."
What this actually does
is fires up a separate
Jetty Server process
that allows the gadget
to be accessed
from the Shindig Server.
Okay?
So I click
"run this application."
And likewise,
I can change various default--
or various settings.
So like, what's the owner,
what's the viewer,
as well as the country
and language,
or if I wanted to see it
in an external Web browser.
So, for this one, because
I already have sample data
in the database--
and that's a feature as well
that's provided--
I'll just select the viewer
as John Doe
and click "Okay."
And so now I'm running the
application entirely locally,
and it's fetching the gadget,
and there we go.
I can see
the actual friends of John Doe
working directly
within the gadget.
So now
I have created my gadget.
I can go ahead
and test it further.
But at this point, I can say,
"Okay, great, I want to go ahead
and create, say, a Java--
an Open Social Java
client application."
And so we have
this feature here in OSDE
that allows you
to create a Java project
for the restful protocol
that will create
a sample bit of code.
So I'll just create
this rest project.
And at that point,
I can just accept the defaults
and hit "Finish."
And that will create
a new project,
and I can click "Yes."
That will allow us to jump
into the Java perspective.
So here we are.
We actually have
a new sample Java client code
that will go
against our local server,
which is still running,
by the way.
And I can go through
and specify--
Instead of, like, CSchalk,
I can say,
"Let's go ahead
and keep it John.Doe,"
which is part
of the sample data.
And at this point,
I can run the application,
since it has
a main method in here.
So I'll just go ahead, click...
"run as Java application."
And then
we'll watch the console.
And as you notice here
in the console,
it actually cre--
you went out and fetched
these same friends
directly from the server,
but this time it was using
the rest protocol.
And that pretty much
concludes the demonstration.
The only other thing
I wanted to show
is that you have, like,
a nice menu option here.
You can also create
the sample data.
So this is actually a first step
that you'd want to do.
I can show you the public
certificate for OAuth.
And I would say that concludes
the demonstration of OSDE,
an Eclipse plug-in
that allows you to do
Open Social Development
entirely inside of Eclipse.
Thank you.